que peut-on faire pour enrayer la
violence autour et dans les stades
un colloque a eu lieu hier à paris alain
vernon nous en explique les conclusions
d'un côté la violence sur le terrain
d'abord contre un arbre ou entre joueurs
en suisse le 8 octobre dans les tribunes
deux bombes qui explosent amsterdam
dimanche dernier 19 blessés au total
dans la rue enfin la police allemande à
la poursuite des hooligans anglais alors
face à cette violence des dirigeants des
éducateurs des chercheurs et surtout des
besoins de comprendre pour tous comme
tribune à l'expression de ses besoins ou
de ces revendications il n'y a pas mieux
qu'un stade de football
l'attention est focalisée les médias
sont présents voilà peut-être deux
éléments très frustré explications qu'il
faut bien entendu creusé dans un
deuxième temps savoir par exemple qu'il
y à trois familles de supporters
violents
les fidèles costumes et les skinheads
proche des extrémistes politiques et les
casseurs professionnels organisés cette
organisation comporte tout ce qu'il faut
pour ne pas se faire attraper par les
contrôles policiers
c'est à dire les tenues tout à fait
correct bad attributs de supporters et
surtout il se donne une règle de
conduite au moins avant pas de boisson
pas de gros pas de solution hors du
terrain sans doute mais schumacher qui
agresse battiston en 82 c'est le sport
professionnel qui dérive et qui manque
surtout à son devoir d'éducation
quant aux sportifs de haut niveau entre
sur un terrain déjà au départ est de
savoir que que des milliers de gamins
ont regardé donc il s'agit d'avoir un
autre exemplaire devant un bon
comportement sur un terrain et ça c'est
déjà c'est important parce que le gamin
va pas s'identifier à vous pour moi
c'est le plus important
deux cartons jaunes seulement en plus de
dix ans de carrière dominique rocheteau
a reçu des mains de roger bambuck le
trophée du fair-play symbolisée ici par
cette tête de bouddha rocheteau
l'exemple de l'exemple bravo